les potins aujourd'hui on va par les
caméras mais pour ça on va pas rester
ici on va aller un tout petit peu plus
loin eh ben on y va ce parti on y va
[Musique]
vous
et salut les amis aujourd'hui et je vous
ai amené à l'ombre pour tester le sony à
7,3 que j'ai dans les mains avec lequel
je filme la juste en ce moment je suis
pas venu exprès à londres pour tester le
sony c'est juste j'avais un job à faire
ici mais je me suis dit que j'allais en
profiter pour vous en parler parce que
cette caméra est vachement intéressante
ah ouais quand même et cette caméra est
vachement intéressante et surtout
c'était aussi l'occasion de parler de
comment est-ce qu'on peut choisir sa
caméra comment bien choisir la caméra
qu'on va utiliser et à des parcs partout
ici je vais essayer de ne pas me faire
écraser
donc on va aller se poser dans un petit
parc tranquille pépère
alors quelques mises au point avant de
démarrer déjà ce sera pas un test ce
sera surtout on avis en fait mon retour
d'expérience sur sept sur sept caméras
c'est les tests c'est bien les gens qui
font ça super bien qu'ils font ça en
long en large et en travers toutes les
spécifications techniques spécificité je
sais pas comment mais c'est très bien
parce que c'est très complet et qu'on
peut en avoir besoin moi ce qui
m'intéresse le plus c'est de savoir au
quotidien
en quoi c'est cool et là je vais juste
te remonter voilà autre petite précision
ce n'est pas une vidéos sponsorisées je
suis pas payée par sony pour dire ce que
je vais dire et enfin juste pour vous
faire une idée je suis passé d'un 5d
cannon marque 3 à se sont ils à pour les
raisons que je vais vous expliquer un
petit peu plus tard dans la vidéo alors
comme tout le monde dès qu'il ya un
nouveau modèle d'appareil photo caméra
qui sort forcément on a cette envie de
l'acheter parce qu'il fait les derniers
trucs qui fait plein de choses que son
appareil ne fait pas c'est pas forcément
une raison en soit de changer sa caméra
ce que ça va pas forcément toujours
amené beaucoup de choses en plus là pour
le coup moi sur mon 5d j'étais quand
même plutôt limité alors je me suis dit
tout simplement qu'est ce que je vais
demander à ma caméra qu'est ce que je
veux qu'elle fasse
et surtout qu'est ce que je fais avec le
souvent et qu'est ce que j'ai envie de
faire
première chose moi je
une belle image donc ça passe par du
full hd minimum et éventuellement de la
4k parce que sur certains projets je
pourrais en avoir besoin le 1080 suffit
amplement mais d'ici 3 4 ans peut-être
que le vrai standard ce sera devenue la
4k donc je veux un appareil qui fasse de
la 4k deuxième point moi je veux
absolument une caméra qui fasse du gros
slow motion
donc qu'ils aillent jusqu'à 100 ou 120
images par seconde en full hd parce que
le slow motion je surkiffe et que vous
avez pu vous en rendre compte dans les
vidéos que je fais il y en a
généralement un petit peu même beaucoup
trop peut-être je sais pas ensuite je
veux des profils l'image qui me permette
d'étalonner de fermat colorimétrie
facilement sans trop me prendre la tête
je veux aussi qu'ils puissent faire des
photos des belles photos genre si j'ai
un mariage courrier ou un concert autre
chose comme ça je veux pas être limité
par l'appareil photo je veux pas que ce
soit dédié 100 % vidéo même si 80 ou 90%
du temps il va faire de la vidéo je veux
avoir la possibilité de faire de belles
photos et dernier truc mais ta gueule le
corbeau leur et dernier truc je veux que
cette caméra elles ne permettent de
gagner du temps jeu que ça aille vite je
veux que si je dois changer de mode
rapidement je veux que ça arrive très
vite je veux pas avoir besoin de
farfouiller dans les menus pendant 107
ans si je veux toucher un réglage je
veux pouvoir la voir au bout du doigt je
veux pas que ça me traîne des pompes
parce que c'est un coup à rater en fait
ce que j'ai envie de filmer alors j'ai
fait ma liste de toutes ces choses là
que je voulais sur une caméra et si je
voulais sachez qu'elle mais tu fous du
bordel tony dron cambon donc déjà mon 5d
mark iii c c'était mort il faisait pas
les trois-quarts de tout ça si je
voulais du slow mauges avait même pas de
la full hd c'était en 720p donc se mène
pas possible enfin voyais plein de trucs
qui me gonfle est une des raisons pour
lesquelles ils m'handicaper en fait sur
certains plans quoi c'était c'était
juste vraiment très handicapante le même
problème c'est que chez canal si je
voulais un truc qu'ils fassent tous ces
trucs là c'était soit 1,5 des marques 4
ou un indé xmarks 2 est là clairement
c'était mais absolument pas dans mes
prix mais alors pas du tout et donc mon
choix il s'est porté sur ce sony à cet
âge mais vous expliqué dans cette vidéo
pourquoi les points qui vraiment ont
fait que je surkiffe cet appareil et que
vraiment il est il est très très
pratique pour moi et je vous expliquerai
aussi les points négatifs parce que il y
en a aussi il ya un truc qui me gonfle
particulièrement mais bon c'est toujours
mieux que ce que j'avais avant mais bon
avant tout ça on va se faire un petit
détour par un lieu que j'aime
particulièrement ici je vais vous
montrer ça tout de suite
on va faire un petit tour dans un
quartier via doha longue séquence the
town
parce que pour profiter quand même fini
pour bosser mais
[Musique]
non
bon retour au calme forcément vu que
j'ai la caméra vous un petit peu ce pôle
est pas ce que je dis je la kiffe et
cette caméra donc forcément c'est que
c'est qu'elle m'a convaincu mais je vais
vous expliquer un petit peu pourquoi
alors le premier truc qui m'a fait
pencher vers le à cette kitoko vérins
gh5 c'est le plein format le à 7 comme
le cannon que j'avais avant et bien il
est plein format ça veut dire que pour
les photos je vais être quand même
vachement plus à l'aise que sur un jeu
f5
si j'avais fait que de la vidéo je pense
que le gh5 peut-être un gh5 pièce je
sais pas avoir mais clairement ce serait
vers ça que je me serais diriger or là
ça m'arrive même si c'est pas la plupart
du temps de faire des photos clairement
le plein format c'est vraiment un point
très positif pour moi pour soi c'est
l'autre truc qui est quand même assez
ouf c'est l'autofocus vidéo le 5d mark
iii et l'avait pas d'autofocus en vidéo
et c'était juste mais une plaie quoi
c'est à dire que ben il fallait faire le
focus soit en manuel ou alors utiliser
coupé l'enregistrement refaire le focus
relancer l'enregistrement c'était juste
catastrophique et là le à 7 il est
monstrueux en autofocus ne vraiment
vraiment monstrueux après comme je vous
disais il ya un mode log l'ouest look 2
et le s l'octroi alors j'avoue que je
maîtrise plus tôt plus le est rock 2
pour le moment je suis d'ailleurs en
train de filmer un an les stocks 2 que
le est l'octroi qui est pas facile du
tout à exposer mais dans tous les cas
après je me régale sur la colorimétrie
c'est vraiment vraiment très très très
sympa le point super important qui m'a
surpris c'est la légèreté ce que l'air
de rien le 5d icahn vachement plus lourd
et à la fin d'une journée quand on fait
une journée de photos une journée de
vidéos s'apaisent graves sur les bras là
le à sète va peser aussi et surtout sur
un stabilisateur mais il va poser quand
même vachement moins et sa fatigue
vraiment vraiment beaucoup moins
les mains les bras pas des gros bras
franchement c'est un gros point positif
ensuite il ya les boutons
personnalisables on peut absolument
personnaliser tous les boutons qu'on
vaut sur cette machine et avec juste un
bouton on peut avoir la fonction dont on
a besoin on peut changer de profil de
l'image on peut changer le mode de focus
on peut changer absolument tout est ce
le paramétrer sur n'importe quel bouton
et ça c'est vraiment ultra pratique faut
prendre le temps de se faire ces
paramètres et puis de s'habituer aussi
aux paramètres pour se rappeler un petit
peu où se trouvent tous les réglages
mais là pour le coup il n'y a plus
besoin d'aller dans les menus kouao
quasiment plus besoin même si je veut
modifier la 4k est passé en 1080 au
moulin vert s'il n'ya pas besoin d'aller
dans les menus on peut se faire des
raccourcis c'est vraiment vraiment super
pratique et ça va très très vite ça
évite de rater en fait des trucs parce
qu'on est en train de bidouiller ses
réglages et camer de trucs que je
voulais filmer se termine et où il est
passé où c'est fini quoi après et à
l'autonomie alors j'avais eu un saunier
à cette première génération
l'autonomie était vraiment pas telle
c'était vraiment pas où cela ils ont
fait des batteries qui sont beaucoup
plus grosse et qui tiennent vraiment
plus longtemps d'ailleurs je suis parti
là pour deux jours et demi donc à
londres c'est pour un tas fin je n'ai
pas fait juste pour tester le à 7 me
disant tiens je vais aller le tester à
l'ombre pop up non j'en ai profité parce
que le cadre est joli mais donc je suis
parti avec deux batteries et je n'ai pas
pris de charger et ça va me suffire
amplement là j'ai tourné pendant
plusieurs heures le site une balade est
pas mal et je suis toujours sur ma
première batterie il doit il restait 80
% à 75 % de charge quoi donc c'est assez
assez impressionnant alors je saurais
pas vous donner un chiffre exact exact
de l'autonomie franchement ça dépend
aussi de comment vous l'utilisez mais
franchement c'est largement suffisant
avec deux batteries je suis tranquille
pour le week-end et enfin le dernier
truc qui avait pas sur mon 5d et qui me
pourrissait la vie c'est la
stabilisation le à 7,3 et stabiliser en
interne
en plus les objectifs que j'ai sont
aussi stabilisés pour peu que je le
mette sur le craignent le stabilisateur
le game boy c'est de la folie c'est
ultra smooth sait on a besoin c'est sûr
c'est sur un drone quoi c'est vraiment
un la thur et ça évite tous les petits
tremblements à la con qui peuvent casser
cette impression de fluidité en fait
qu'on peut avoir dans les mouvements
même en soule motion
mais je vous rassure il n'y a pas que du
positif en plus il ya quand même deux
points qui me gonfle particulièrement
mais pour ça on va bouger en valais un
petit peu plus loin et je vais vous
expliquer tout ça alors du coup les deux
trucs qui me gonfle rien et j'ai compris
vraiment pas pourquoi sony n'y a rien
fait pour ça c'est qu'il n'ya pas
d'écran géant vers cible c'est-à-dire
que d'accord je me film là bas c'est un
peu avoue pif il n'y a pas forcément de
retour ça c'est assez gênant chez moi ça
va parce que j'ai un moniteur mais en
extérieur c'est pas évident et puis
l'autre c'est le prix des objectifs quoi
qui coûte mais c'est même plus un bras
lasser les drains quoi ces objectifs
sont super cher alors heureusement il ya
sigma qui arrivent sur le marché d'issy
pas longtemps donc ça va peut-être faire
baisser les prix et il faut espérer que
j'espérais que ce soit abordable mais là
pour le coup j'ai dû me contenter de
objectif pas forcément ultra ultra haut
de gamme qui font graveleux tu as faim
et pas de soucis mais c'est vrai que ça
c'est les deux seuls trucs qui me
font une fois embauché n'en reste plus
qu'à faire la peau plus jeunes
[Musique]
alors pour finir comment bien choisir sa
caméra comment faire en sorte que ce
soit le le plus optimale possible sans
forcément débourser les sommes
astronomiques parce que forcément à des
prix ultra cher on va avoir des choses
ultra bien et encore peut-être pas
toujours
ben moi ce que je vous conseille c'est
tout simplement de faire comme j'ai fait
moi c'est à dire ouvert une liste des
fonctionnalités que vous voulez à voir
avec votre caméra des fonctionnalités
dont vous allez vous servir ce qui va
vraiment vous servir pour faire vos
vidéos partant de là pour regarder les
caméras qui bénéficient de ces
fonctionnalités là et après bah c'est
une histoire de primes d'en voir en
fonction de votre budget de moi pour le
coup avec sa c3 je suis maire ravi de
chez rage il me simplifie la vie à plein
de niveaux
il me permet de faire vraiment
rapidement et simplement plein de choses
là tout ce que je fais en extérieur
depuis les deux dernières vidéos ça
aurait été vraiment très galère avec le
5d ici c'est super simple super simple
c'est relativement simple et c'est
franchement cool mais surtout attention
à pas tomber dans le piège de vouloir
acheter toujours la dernière caméra je
dis ça je suis mal placée en moi le
premier j'ai toujours envie dès juin
nous autres qui sort ça me va voilà
c'est je suis un peu tenté mais voilà
l'idée si si c'était d'acheter une
caméra que j'allais garder longtemps
qu'ils allaient être performante pendant
longtemps aussi ça c'est un point à
prendre en compte
c'est sûr que si on dépense des des
petites sommes on va dire pour un
appareil parce qu'on n'a pas forcément
le budget peut-être autant attendre un
petit peu mettre de côté et s'acheter
quelque chose qui va vraiment durée et
sur lequel on sera pas frustré parce
qu'au final le 5d je l'avais acheté pas
très cher d'occasion et au final j'ai
très vite été frustré parce que il me
bloquer ou m'empêcher de faire vraiment
ce que j'avais envie de faire et le
résultat était même s'il était bien
c'est pas ça mais le résultat me
dsv à certains moments donc là pour
l'instant
sonia 7,3 je suis con qui ravit c'est
vraiment vraiment une super caméra et
voilà les amis c'est déjà fini j'espère
que cette vidéo vous avez plus si c'est
le cas n'hésitez pas à exploser le pouce
en l'air qui se situe en dessous de
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas également à
vous abonner si c'est pas encore le cas
un grand merci à romain qui est le tout
premier type heures de la chaîne merci
beaucoup romain ça fait super plaisir
et puis moi je vous dis en attendant
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo
[Musique]